we're here in the permian basin of west
texas where some say
this leaking well could be the sign of a
bigger problem under our feet
this chevron well was designed to inject
oil field wastewater
deep underground and it did so for
decades
it was plugged more than 25 years ago
but it started to leak the very
same toxic water it was designed to get
rid of
chevron sent crews to fix the leak and
find out what happened
but with other leaking wells and
pipelines on the same ranch
the landowner and others fear an
ecological disaster could be taking
place
i'm a fourth generation west texas
rancher
my great grandfather came out here in
1914 and we've been working cattle in
west texas
ever since the problem today is that we
have a chevron well
blowing out that was previously plugged
and abandoned we don't know why it's
blowing out
which is even more concerning than the
blowout itself we also have a number
other wells that are having various
casing issues pressure issues etc this
is a symptom of the problem this is not
the problem itself the problem is the
other hundreds of wells on this ranch
alone
extrapolating thousands of wells in the
permian tens of thousands
how many of those are going to collapse
even it's only one percent that's 100
wells
that are going to pollute aquifers and
destroy huge swaths of land
our water out here is at 53 feet so any
contaminants that get to the surface
are going to get in our water system and
we live in a very dry climate so if we
lose our water
we don't have a ranch people can't live
here cattle can't live here nothing can
live here
right now we are destroying this aquifer
and i legitimately don't know if it can
ever be fixed
like it is a very open question whether
any amount of money in the world
can make this right
what's happening here remains under
investigation but some fear it's the
sign of a wider scale problem
one where hundreds or even thousands of
old wells in the nation's most prolific
oil field
could also start leaking some say it
could be a
potential problem one that both industry
and regulators will have to deal with